so the best advice clearly would be for
individuals to present to the unhcr the
United Kingdom like many countries Works
closely with the unhcr and we already
operate safe and legal routes in
partnership with them that safe and
legal route is available today and in
fact the UK is the fourth largest
recipient of any country in the world of
individuals through those routes
operated by the unhcr so his Central
contention that the UK is somehow not a
generous and compassionate country
though we are not working with
organizations like the UN HCR in this
regard is factually incorrect
oh let's bring John Craig back in he's
had one eye on what's been unfolding at
Stansted Airport there's UK Nationals
arriving back into Britain and the other
eye and what's been unfolding in the
House of Commons because while that
flight was arriving at Stansted Airport
the debate continued in the House of
Commons uh where did we get to with that
ahead of tonight's vote
well I think I'm right in saying that Mr
generic that clip we heard just there
was responding to the uh snps Joanna
Cherry now she is a leading KC and
really is the snp's uh legal brain
really uh expert on these matters now
she has made the claim during the course
of the uh this debate which is on a
government Amendment which would allow
Sue Ella bravman to disregard some
rulings by the uh a European Court of
Human Rights Joanna Cherry has said that
elements of this bill and that is the
this bill the illegal migration Bill 60
pages of it pretty uh weighty piece of
legislation it would allow ministers
Jonah Cherry says to breach
international law and she asked why the
home secretaries refused to appear
before the Juke Joint Committee on human
rights which she chairs uh to justify
her admission that the Bill's not
compatible now she is um referring to a
statement on the front of this bill
which we've discussed more already here
on Sky News
this is Sue Ella bravaman's statement on
the front of the bill where she says I
am unable to make a statement that in my
view the provisions of the illegal
migration Bill are combat compatible
with the convention rights but the
government nevertheless Wishes the house
to proceed with this bill now I remember
this came up a lot at second reading and
the early stages of the um of the
committee stages Committee of the whole
house because it's such an important
bill not as they say a committee
upstairs with just a small number of MPS
but so that's a clash with Joanna Cherry
but let me tell you uh something quite
significant Jeffrey Cox the Sir Jeffrey
Cox I believe he is these days uh former
Attorney General has made a dramatic
Infamous intervention asking
isn't the minister in fact asking this
house to give legislative sanction to at
least the possibility that a minister of
the crown will deliberately disobey the
international law obligations of this
country so that is a senior Tory joining
the attack on the government now Mr
Generac has said in response to that
that the
the UK takes its treaty obligations very
seriously but then Sir Jeffrey hit back
and said MPS are being asked to approve
quite consciously and deliberately a
deliberate breach of our obligations
under the e c a echr European Court of
Human Rights one other piece of news
looks like the government's going to
avoid a rebellion on the illegal
migration bill on the amendment from Tim
Lawton he put down an amendment on child
refugees and unaccompanied children but
he's now told Sky News he's happy with
what Mr generic has told him
um uh in the during the course of the
debate so it's all getting quite heated
in the House of Commons with a surprise
and what's uh by all accounts are pretty
dramatic intervention by a former
Attorney General Sir Jeffrey Cox in a
clash with Mr generic who is taking the
bill through the commons today report
stage and third reading it will complete
its Passage through the commons tonight
but of course will be big clashes in the
House of Lords in the weeks to come